let's go next to our caller from the
nine five four area code who's calling
today from 954 hello yeah that's you
hey David how are you man uh although
I'm right-wing I have watched your shows
a couple of months now and honestly just
want to say I really appreciate you
being as genuine as you can and you know
hopefully not to bias alright but my
question is more on a personal note a
bit uh-oh I'm in college right now and
I've been thinking of you know stop
majoring in political science but I'm
kind of naive when it comes to the
opportunities that may lead with that
any any information you may give me or
anywhere else I can take with you here's
my view I think that call it basically
is primarily for in a lot of different
majors it is to learn how to think learn
how to learn learn how to exist in
environments that are different than
just with family and friends and
starting to learn you know behaving
diplomatically and managing
relationships and these types of things
and also I wish that maybe things were
different but so much of what exists in
terms of opportunities is not so much
about like the subject matter that you
memorize and learn in college but about
understanding that this is a world that
depends on relationships and networking
and who you know so for me you know if
the idea is to major in political
science and get an internship with an
elected official and use that to maybe
become an aide to Apple you know that
there's sort of a path there but for me
mostly political science is like listen
you could do Poli Sci you could do
philosophy you could do psychology you
could do sociology you could do
economics or a lot of these are
understanding how to think and learn and
a lot of the job opportunities will be
very similar no matter where you get a
four-year degree for uh no matter which
as a major you have for your four-year
degree and it's mostly going to come
down to are you good at building
relationships are you a go-getter in
terms of getting internships and talking
to people so it's really like
if you're interested in it do it but you
really need to think about what it is
you want to be doing when you're when
you're out of college wow what a great
answer David I appreciate it and I also
want to say quickly I really enjoyed you
having Sam Harris on the show I'm a big
fan of both of you but have a great day
David all right thank you so much a very
very polite right-winger and that's a
delightful delightful thing to see